I'm I'm concerned where the city is
going because this is simple math
and
we're not doing very well on the test
really I am
I in person
always believed
to make um and I love clear water
and I love some of the things that we've
gotten done
I think imagine is going to be
a little
I think Miss poyer is going to do a
great job as City man
but
in good conscience
for my family for my own health and
other things
I can't remain in America
my name is Frank Gifford I'm the former
mayor of Clearwater as of uh this past
Monday I've been mayor and on the city
council for 13 years two different
stents my real job though has always
been a financial advisor and wealth
manager and so that's always informed my
decisions when it came to City affairs
well we've always been really a very
conservative and fiscally uh conscious
City we've had very little debt uh but
the spreadsheets that we were looking at
this past Monday showed a number of
projects and the funding shortfall was a
quarter of a billion dollars
and there's only a couple ways that you
can pay for that you can raise taxes
uh where you can float bonds and go into
debt further and I don't think that
those are viable alternatives
and after asking my fellow council
members if they really supported uh this
project as their number one choice and
listening to all four of them I had a
light bulb moment and said I am not the
right person to lead these folks anymore
and I took a recess talked to my wife
for a moment and felt that it was best
that I go ahead and resign from my
position a year before my term is over
well we were having a budget meeting uh
on strategies moving forward and some of
the large expenditures that were going
to be made uh within the city and we've
had a city hall that uh has been
envisioned that I don't believe is
necessary there's other ways to go about
it and the price that ballooned from
originally uh 40 million dollars to 90
million dollars and as we all know with
cost overruns on construction I'm
concerned that it will uh eventually
rise over a hundred million dollars I
think local government government
General needs to be very careful with
their
resources and also be more creative in
the way we solve problems
office work is going to be very
different in the next couple of years we
don't know what it's going to look like
and so building a new uh facility I
think is reckless
Clearwater is again financially still
sound uh but we have a number of
priorities that have to be prioritized
one of the top V top one for the four
City Council Members is a new city hall
Municipal Services building that means
that other projects that affect our
citizens on a daily basis probably will
not go forward
it's a matter of wants and needs
and this new city hall is not a need
it's simply a want